hello again fellow hunters here's a
quick guide on how to get a secret
weapon the holy moonlight sword in order
to get the holy moonlight sword you will
need to defeat Ludwig who has turned
into some type of demonic horse beast
I'll avoid spoilers on the actual fight
but once you've defeated him you'll
notice that his head still remains in
the room go ahead and listen to his
final words before he goes crazy and I
can't stop neighing uncontrollably after
talking to him go ahead and finish off
the horse head once you've done that
you'll be able to pick up the holy
moonlight sword the holy moonlight sword
seems like a pretty ordinary sword and
it's one-handed form however once
swapped a two-handed mode it glows a
nice teal color and shoots projectiles
while pressing r2 when firing off a
projectile a quick silver bullet will be
consumed you can also charge the r2 for
a stronger projectile that is sent at a
diagonal angle a non charge r2 will just
shoot straight ahead the holy moonlight
sword is a strengthened arcane based
weapon and it swings very similarly to
Ludwig's holy blade stay tuned again
spot.com for continuing coverage of
blood-borne new expansion the old
hunters
you